herzlich willkommen zur sternstunde
religion im irak und in syrien
schlachten derzeit brutale gotteskrieger
im namen allahs menschen anderen
glaubens ab hier wird der islam in sein
gegenteil pervertiert sagen die einen
nein der islam selbst ist gewalttätig
und trägt faschistische züge sagt hamed
abdel-samad der politikwissenschaftler
ist heute gast bei mir
er stellt sich der kritik von murat doch
mit meinem zweiten gast der islam
theologie lehrt in münster und sagt
exakt das gegenteil
islam ist barmherzigkeit und das setzt
ein barmherzigen gott voraus herr pelzer
man um himmels willen wie kommen sie zu
dieser these der islam prägt
faschistische züge
wir müssen uns fragen was bedeutet
faschismus wie definiert man faschismus
der faschismus für mich ist eine
politische religion nicht nur eine
politische ideologie eine ideologie die
die welt in gut und böse unterteilt
freund und feind eine ideologie die die
eigenen anhänger mit hass und
ressentiments gegen anders denken und
andersgläubige er vergiftet eine
ideologie die nach weltherrschaft strebt
eine ideologie die antisemitisch ist
eine ideologie die von der eigenen
auserwähltheit ausgehend und das ist der
islam auch und das alles verbinden sie
mit dem islam auch in ihrem buch der
islamische faschismus faschismus
vergleiche sind verpönt sie leben in
deutschland gerade in deutschland gerade
in deutschland finde ich dieser
vergleich ist wichtig gerade in
deutschland versteht man was es bedeutet
wenn eine gruppe sich über die
menschheit erhebt und glaubt alle
anderen sein dieser gruppe unterlegen
moralisch und menschlich wenn eine
gruppe die eigenen anhänger
entmenschlicht oder als untermenschen
betracht
wenn dieser gruppe mit ihren mit ihrer
ideologie durchkommt dann erleben wir
szenen wie in deutschland zwischen 33
und 45
aber auch in syrien und irak erleben wir
genau die gleichen szenen jetzt weil
eine gruppe eine ähnliche geologie
verfolgt die eigenen gegner alles unter
mensch betrachtet und deshalb auch deren
totale vernichtung in kauf nimmt
die weltherrschaft dass ein teil in gut
und böse was sagen sie zum faschismus
vorwurf gegen den islam
zuerst grundsätzliches es gibt die
muslime und es gibt die islamische
tradition und beide sind in einem
prozess in interaktion miteinander und
dadurch wird ein narrativ erzeugt also
dadurch wird auch tradition erzeugt weil
wir muslime so unterschiedlich sind wir
leben in unterschiedlichen kontexten wir
erzeugen unterschiedliche traditionen
unterschiedlicher noch relative über den
islam
wenn sie einen muslim heute in syrien
fragen was er unter s bahn versteht im
irak in saudi arabien in australien hier
in der schweiz oder in deutschland
sie werden sehr unterschiedliche
antworten bekommen und das ist alles der
islam
diese bandbreite das heißt den islam
gibt es gar nicht hier spürt man schon
den professor oder der unterscheidet sie
lehren in münster sind leiten dieses
zentrums für islamische theologie hier
sitzt der politikwissenschaft hat er
auch sprachen studiert hat der autor
faschismus vorwurf was sagen sie dazu
das heißt wenn wir unterschiedliche
narrativen über den islam
da gibt es auch ein verständnis vom
islam das was wir heute gerade in irak
erleben was die sogenannte islamische
staat produziert einen verstehen es von
islam und da stimmt einiges über ein mit
dem was damals sagt in dieser ideologie
was wichtig ist dass wir sie hier
unterscheiden von welchem narrativ
sprechen wird gerade von welche
islamischen tradition sprechen wird
verlieren wir unseren der islam ist so
oder sind es bestimmte nachrichten
bestimmte erzählungen über den islam die
manche muslime vertreten
die vielleicht berechtigt sind mit dem
vorwurf diese ideologie ist gefährlich
jetzt also ob man das jetzt mit dem
begriff faschismus bezeichnet eine
andere diskussion ist es immer schwierig
begriffe aus einem kontext hinein zu
produzieren ein anderes kontext aber man
kann bestimmte lesarten des islams
berechtigterweise kritisieren aber da
muss man schon differenzieren
sie würden sagen bei es in syrien irak
würden sie es gab noch knapp durchgehen
lassen faschismus vergleich habe das
richtige haus gehört aber sonst mit der
vorwurf der pauschalisierung wir haben
vorhin gesagt was ist faschismus dann
sagen wie was des islams das herzstück
des islam
das ist der koran der prophet und seiner
tradition wenn die hunde gewährt und
nicht dabei ich rede jetzt vom herzstück
das so dass es wirklich was unumstritten
ist das ist das prophet als vorbild und
dass es der koran alles ein buch das
leitung auch für muslime gibt nicht nur
spirituell leitung sondern auch
handlungsanleitung wenn wenn wir lesen
in der biografie des propheten dass der
prophet arabien und juden und christen
reingemacht hat alle ungläubig der
arabischen halbinsel vertrieben hat und
im islam durchgesetzt hat wenn wir lesen
dass er an einem tag 600 wehrlose juden
im trauten ließ raubten dies deren
frauen versklavt und die kinder auch
dieses leute nehmen den propheten alles
ein vorbild wenn wie im koran lesen dass
gott den sie barmherzig nennen
25 mal direkt tötungsbefehl an die
gläubigen muslim an unglauben direkte
tötungsbefehl
tötet enthauptet sie verstümmelt sie
dann kann man nicht sagen das hat doch
mit dem islam nichts zu tun oder die ss
leute haben dem koran falsch verstanden
sie beziehen ihre legitimation direkt
aus der biografie des propheten und aus
dem koran
also stimmt was hast du gesagt das ist
jetzt richtig ist weg die geschichte mal
von mohammed und danach dass das so im
chorraum das stimmt es für ihren kern
haben natürlich haben wir den koran die
aussagen des propheten nur wie der
vierte kalif der imam ali gesagt hat der
chor anspricht nicht sondern die
menschen bringen ihn zum spricht sich
sprechen
durch ihn das heißt der koran ist da wir
haben die prophetische tradition wir
haben nationen
die frage ist welche lesart will sich
jetzt dem koran und was hole ich raus
aus dem koran ich gebe ein provokantes
beispiel dass er besonders gerade kurz
angeschnitten hat jahre 627 es wird
erzählt wenn man in der biografie des
propheten bremen as sieht in der tat gab
es ein 1 1 ein jüdischer stamm beide
kreise die fahrrad ausgeübt haben einem
krieg zwischen den propheten amerikaner
es hat einen vertrag gegeben zwischen
dem propheten und dieser jüdischen
diesen jüdischen staat
die haben den vertrag abgebrochen und
krieg mitgeführt mit den metallern gegen
mohammed daraufhin gibt es jetzt
unterschiedliche eine relative was hat
er mit ihnen gemacht sie werden in
überzahl lesen zwischen 400 nicht nur
600 bis 900 geht es der angeblich an
einem tag umgebracht hat nicht nur die
am krieg beteiligt waren
jetzt lesen sie bei den bei der
prophetischen tradition dieses wunder
bei bukhari bei muslim das ereignis
dort werden keine zahlen erwähnt und
dort wird gesagt nur die krieger jetzt
lesen sie einander innovativen der
geschichte ein buch kita villa mal heißt
das mit einer authentischen
überlieferung skelette dort ist die rede
nur von 40 meter elektriker die
geschlachtet
wir haben hier zahlen 40 400 600 700 bis
900 die an einem tag angebliches
ermordet wurden die frage ist warum gibt
es so unterschiedlicher narrativen es
ist
ist bekannt er neigte dazu die biografie
des propheten zu glorifizieren
je mehr der prophet umgebracht hat desto
stärker männlicher mächtiger ist er
übrigens lesen wird genauso über
sexualität des propheten angeblich 30
mal mehr potenz hätte als ein
normalsterblicher warum machen die leute
damals das weil sie in ihrem content
gedacht haben sie tun den propheten
etwas gutes ansehen aufblähen drohung
genommen werden kritisieren sie diese
tradition
naja das ist das also dann kommt jemand
und nimmt einen negativ und sagt das
nehme ich auch das eben erst ist nicht
nur ein narrativ das ist das buch
schlicht hin dass die geschichte des
propheten er erzählt von allen
islamischen gelehrten anerkannt alles
die geschichte des propheten wurde nie
angegriffen von dem theologen doch sogar
von yamaha team hat über ihn gesagt er
ist ein lügen ja sogar also da gibt es
aber wie wird sie sehen dass so wenig
und da haben sie vollkommen recht wenn
wir uns nicht historisch kritisch mit
diesen themen auseinandersetzung sein
wenn es harte 200 jahre übrigen gesagt
den tod des propheten seine biografie
geschrieben hat können sich vorstellen
was dazwischen alles ein elemente
eingeflossen sind
das wird uns auseinandersetzen objektiv
auch mit ines haack und seines nicht vom
himmel gefallen und der müssen wir
muslime uns ernsthaft mit dem
auseinandersetzen überlegen kann sein
dass da alles so in stein gemeißelt ist
was drinnen ist oder gibt es andere
negative für die wird uns stark machen
was ist nur ein satz was ich da zu sein
wollte ist die frage warum nimmt ein
esel ist mensch das eine narrativ sagt
nein also ich ekel sich sogar wenn er
das hört mit den 40
er will die 900 lieber sogar um zu
zeigen nein mohammed war doch stark und
er will sich ja mit einem starken
mohammed identifizieren die der menschen
umgebracht hat und warum nämlich in
münster wenn ich meine studierenden aus
mitte er das andere innovativen mit den
40 natürlich mit argumenten für gardinen
sei nicht sagen warum wir diese leute
die sehr aktive nehmen weil sie
vergleichen die generativen aus der
propheten tradition mit dem was im koran
steht und das stimmt überein
wenn gott wenn wir den koran 206
passagen über gewalt und krieg und töten
stehen wo gott sie selbst den sie beim
herzlich nennen alles krieger bezeichnet
der auf der seite der muslime kämpft er
seitdem propheten im koran
du hast sie nicht getötet sondern alle
hat sie getötet du hast nicht mit dem
speer geworfen allah hat
wenn gott sich selbst als krieger
betätigt auf der seite eine gruppe gegen
andere gruppe menschen die er angeblich
auch selber geschaffen haben dass dieses
leute sehen dass und merken es gibt kein
unterschied wenn die wii kann wie kann
mohammed eine barmherzige religion
zustande bringen wenn wir lesen dass er
in den acht in den letzten acht jahren
seines lebens 80 bis 90 kriege geführt
haben hat uns herr eier
das bedeutet jeden monat ein neuer krieg
jeden monat ein neuer gewann kam so ein
mensch eine gesellschaft stabilisieren
oder zu stande bringen die von
barmherzigkeit redet wissen sie welcher
barmherzigkeit und ich habe ihr buch
gelesen
die barmherzigkeit die im koran und in
der propheten traktion vorhanden ist ist
dem barmherzigkeit der muslime
untereinander das steht auch im koran
mohammed und seine gefährten sind
untereinander barmherzig und gegenüber
den ungläubigen haben das ist genau der
unterschied klar und ich über spitze
dass auch die nationalsozialisten war
auch untereinander barmherzig hitler war
auch nett zu seinem hund war auch hat
auch freundschaften hat auch menschliche
seiten aber gegenüber den anderen waren
die nationalsozialisten unmenschlich und
gegenüber den feinden weil auch die
muslime nicht nur zu zeiten von
mohammeds sondern in der traditions-
geschichte auch unbarmherzig greifen
steht der vorwurf des food
zentralismus jetzt gegen sie im raum
oder sie greifen ein teil der tradition
heraus vergleichen sie denn mohammed mit
hitler
man darf natürlich ein mensch aus dem
siebten jahrhundert nicht mit einem
menschen aus dem zwanzigsten jahrhundert
vergleichen aber mohammed und seine
gebote sind nicht im siebten jahrhundert
geblieben sondern die kommen jetzt und
haben den anspruch sich politisch
mitzumischen
ihre konzepte in der welt nicht nur in
der islamischen welt sondern in der
ganzen welt zu durchzusetzen und deshalb
muss ich auch mohammed und den koran mit
dem markt und ist 21 jahrhundert auch
beurteilen
man kann natürlich einen deal machen
wenn man tatsächlich reform haben will
dass ich den propheten mit den maßstäben
von heute nicht beurteilen aber dass
auch der prophet sich nicht einmischt
aber diese rechnung sie plötzlich von
tradition ja es ist es ist natürlich wir
sitzen hier und wir wissen nicht
wirklich wer mohamed war und wie er war
was am ende bleibt sind die texte wie
diese texte wahrgenommen werden wie sie
gelebt werden in der islamischen
geschichte und wie der prophet alles
vorbild erlebt und gelebt wird und das
was die dieses leute machen ist nichts
anders als dieser tradition die weit
verbreitet ist und anerkannt ist ich
ging zur schule in ägypten und habe
inhalte gelernt die mit der ideologie
der chor sind die tatsache dass wir
beide an der zivilisation herangewachsen
sind
das ermöglicht uns eine gewisse
distanzierung wo wir sagen wir sind
gegen hände abhacken wir sind gegen
enthauptungen wir sind wir aber das
alles hat es im islam gegeben
die tatsache dass viele nette muslime
gibt bedeutet nicht das ist die lehre
des islam sondern das ist ein segen dass
die mehrheit der muslime dem islam nicht
so umsetzt
als sie verstrickte sich in widersprüche
jetzt gibt es andere tradition es gibt
andere auslegungen der interpretation
des islam und sie sagen der islamische
faschismus ist nicht der titel und die
stoßrichtung falsch ist das nicht heißen
der islamistische faschismus nein ich
meine natürlich der ausgangspunkt des
buches der islamische faschismus ist ein
vergleich zwischen den islamistischen
bewegungen und dem den faschistischen
bewegung beide übrigens sind aus dem aus
der gleichen epoche geboren in den 20er
jahren die islamistischen bewegungen in
ägypten und in indien seien auch den
faschismus als vorbild und die idee des
das führerprinzip die auserwähltheit der
traum von der weltherrschaft natürlich
beeinflussten sie sich gegenseitig aber
der islamismus ist nicht ein neues
phänomen in der islamischen welt ist der
islamismus ist genauso alt wie die
islamische geschichte selbst
es waren nicht die modernen islamisten
wie die weltherrschaft angestellt haben
zum ersten mal sondern das ist der
anspruch des islam seit anbeginn was hat
der islam dann sonst in ägypten irak und
syrien und andalusien gemacht gesucht wo
hat er sich verteidigt das war expansion
dass diese expansion speist sich aus dem
koran heraus der sagt die religion bei
allah ist islam und seine aufgabe als
prophet ist den islam durchzusetzen um
über alle anderen religionen zu siegen
das ist das was mohammed und seine
gefährten gemacht haben und dass das was
die eroberungskriege danach gemacht
haben und das ist genau das was diese
leute auch im irak vor haben zu
behaupten das hat alles mit dem islam
nichts zu tun das ist eine falsche
leseart nein das ist das herzstück das
ist rekord das ist er jetzt viele
vorwürfe im rahmen
sie haben selber ägyptische wurzeln sie
sind im libanon geboren in saudi arabien
auf
wachsen sie haben dann in wien
soziologie studiert leben jetzt heute in
deutschland also zwei unterschiedliche
hintergründe zwei muslime die jetzt
streiten mit einem doch mal erklären
eines ihrer bücher heißt islam ist
barmherzigkeit wie sie denn bei diesen
bei dieser vorlage das bis jetzt mal
erklären
folgendes also wenn er ab zusammen sagt
zum beispiel ich vergleiche mohammed mit
hitler welchen mohammed sie sagen selber
wir haben unterschiedliche erzählungen
die erste biografie des propheten wir
kennen die entstand 200 jahre nach
seinem tod
es gibt sehr viele unter also nicht nur
unterschiedliche widersprüchliche
innovative über den propheten über
auslegungen des korans selbst die frage
ist warum entscheidet sich eine person
en theologe eine gruppe wie immer für
die eine interpretation nicht für die
anderen
wir beschäftigen uns zu sehr mit
abstrakten wir sollten uns auch zugleich
mit den menschen beschäftigen und uns
fragen diese menschen die interaktion
mit der tradition stehen warum
selektieren sie was steckt dahinter
das sei dieses mensch lieber diese
lesart haben will dass ich lieber die
andere lesart und der dritte eine andere
dritte leser haben will
das heißt auch die die stellen die jetzt
angedeutet wohnen im koran die die in
der tat kriegerische
auseinandersetzungen ansprechen
sie liest man diese stellen als
imperativ historisch über geschichte
schon sagt da spricht ein gott hier
autorität für alle zeiten tötet und
gläubige wo immer sie ihr findet oder
geht es um einen historischen kontext
und wo wird das alles kontext
realisieren um zu sagen
daraus können wir keine allgemeine
aussagen ableiten für alle zeiten
sondern in einem bestimmten historischen
kontext wird etwas in einem bestimmten
in einem bestimmten sprache zum ausdruck
gebracht und da müssen wir uns damit
auseinandersetzen mit dem 6 1 ist sie
mal als reform theologen der eben
versucht den koran nicht alles in stein
gemeißeltes wort zu sehen der versuchte
die tradition des islam in die heutige
zeit hinein
zu interpretieren aber woher beziehen
sie diesen islam der barmherzigkeit
folgendes was sehr zentral ist mein
ausgangspunkt ist das barmherzigkeit als
wissens attribut gottes was heißt ein
wesen das attribut das heißt ein wesen
das attribut ein ewiges attribut davon
gibt es kein gegensatz also gott ist
nicht manchmal warmherzig und manchmal
unbarmherzig sondern ist über die ganze
strecke hinweg immer warmherzig und
alles andere was wir in gott also wie
gut sich beschreibt dem koran auch als
der strafende gott zum beispiel das ist
teil seiner barmherzigkeit das ist meine
these wenn ich von einer theologie der
barmherzigen geld also welche gründe sie
auch mit dem koran für die die den koran
ich glaube natürlich natürlich winde
koran silva an also warum beginnt der
koran immer wieder diesen mit mit dieser
formel im namen gottes deshalb nahmen
herzen also offensichtlich will dieser
gott sich so mitteilen dass er sagt
aufpassen bevor du weiter liest denkt
immer daran ich bin der warmherzig
wiener selber sagt meine strafe erreicht
wenig möchte aber meine barmherzigkeit
umfasst alle dinge
das heißt er relativiert hier seine
strafe aber macht seine barmherzigkeit
absolut und wenn ich sage gottes
barmherzig ist lebt er in ich sonst das
gefällt mir gerade und deshalb nehme ich
das und blinde ich etwas aus sondern ich
sage die barmherzigkeit ist absolut und
das strafende gott das ist die relative
gott wenn gottes barmherzigkeit absolut
ist dann sind ist sie zu allen lebewesen
zu allen menschen rupp gläubige
nichtgläubige immer barmherzig das ist
meine these und das ist mein
ausgangspunkt warum ich sage islams
barmherzigkeit weil der islam gegen
mohammed versetzte seine gegner durch
gewalt in angst und schrecken und
pflanze die saat der intoleranz in das
herz des islam
ihr buch der islamische faschismus 2014
erschienen
diese tradition das ist eine erzählung
über mohammed
nein ich bin ja für historisierung und
kritische leser art des krans aber es
ist amüsant wenn ich von vom islamischen
faschismus sprecher
dann fragt man mich von welchem islam
reden sie überhaupt aber wenn sie sagen
islam ist barmherzigkeit kommt keiner
und sagt von welchem islam reden sie
dankbar dafür ja tradition sich herr
auch im beruf
selbstverständlich sind die
kriegerischen passage im koran
historisch so verstehen dass waren
konkrete kriegssituationen wo krieg
zwischen muslimen und ungläubigen
stattgefunden hat und dieser
tötungsbefehl beziehen sich auf dieser
zeit aber auch die barmherzigkeit und
der frieden im koran ist auch historisch
zu verstehen und nicht für alle zeiten
gilt wenn es im koran steht und wenn sie
euch die hand zufrieden strecken dann
oder wenn sie zum frieden neigen dann
schließt auch fliegen mit ihm das war
eine strategische aktion die zwei jahre
später aufgehoben wurde den muhammad hat
dann gegen die leute krieg geführt mit
den zwei jahren davor gemacht hat alles
mohammed in mekka oder die muslime in
mekka noch eine kleine minderheit waren
da waren all dieser warmherzigen
passagen da weil aus der situation einer
minderheit heraus aus dem bewusstsein
eines verfolgten heraus kann man
wunderbar tolerant und offen und ist man
eigentlich für vielfalt dankbar da hat
mohammed in ein amerikanisches uhr den
ungläubigen matter gesagt glauben und
mir mein glaube und später als
ahmadinedschad ging und er war er wollte
mit den juden irgendwie eine annäherung
starten dann hat er gesagt es gibt
keinen zwang im glauben da steht mit mir
lichtung koran
aber diese passagen sind frühere
passagen alles
wir haben wir noch keine armee hatte
alles eher eine armee hatte dann war
alles weg da musste der koran sich
durchsetzen dann ging ihr nach mekka und
hat mit zurückerobert die restliche
summe gedroht hat ist mit 10.000 mann
und sie leute kann haben die fackeln
schon gesehen und hatten angst gehabt
und deshalb konnten sie nichts und was
hat er mit denen gemacht er hat ihre
kurzen bilder zerstört die amazone habe
ihr habt ihr habt acht umgebracht weil
er seine rückkehr nach market maker
nicht akzeptiert habe
und die kamen zu machen habe ihm gesagt
eben achter will nicht und dann hat er
gesagt er tötet ihn
dann hat dann haben sie gesagt der nimmt
in kabul wo kein mensch ein mensch
umbringen sollte und dann hat er gesagt
tötet ihn auch wenn er am körper hängt
das waren dafür angesetzt als wäre alles
eine minderheit war dann war er für
vielfalt als er zurückkam gab es dieser
vielfalt nicht mehr er hat dann die
ganzen bilder amerikaner das heißt auch
ihre religion was er gesagt hat ich
glaube mir mein glaube als mohammed nach
mckagan ist war wirklich am höhepunkt
seiner militärischen stärke waren so
kurz vor seinem tod in der tat
zehntausende sind in allen krank die
anderen haben sich sofort ergeben
sondern gesehen wir haben keine chance
wer waren diese anderen dem egger das
waren die die muslime über jahrzehnte
gefoltert haben sie haben ihn gefragt
was passiert jetzt mit uns und er hat
sie gefragt was glaubt ihr was ich mit
euch machen und was erzählt uns die
geschichte
es gibt nur diese eine vision übrigens
der geschichte er hat ihnen gesagt sowie
josef also profitieren
seine geschwister gegeben hat ist für
gebe euch geht ihr seid alle frei diese
stelle gibt es nicht in der islam und
das netz als erzählung aber sagen sie
mir sie sind jetzt islam wir
hinterfragen sie mir da ist das im
buchhandel ist das in ebenes haag wo
gibt es diese stelle ist eine erzählung
die nachher will ihren geschichten genau
das ist meine empfehlung dass sie das
ist dann beliebig sie suchen sich jetzt
eine passage aus die nicht hinter solch
ein verhalten ist nirgendwo alles sei
die frage ist eben er hat er hat dem ik
einfach frage was denn die haben mit der
gelebten mekka er hat sie nicht
geschlachtet es gibt kein einziges team
gab es neben islam in mekka danach es
gibt keine erzählung dass mohammed in
mekka dann abgeschlachtet hat oder sogar
die stärke hat also gerade in seine
stärkste frage aber diese stellen möchte
warum nimmt man eine einzelperson es
gibt ein oder eine einzelperson der
getötet wurde
und es gibt es dann viele tausend
zehntausende sogar wenn nicht mehr so
weit über 100.000 weil die muslime schon
bald auch unter 20.000 der male gezeigt
wie so blendet man eine relative nennt
man sich ein narrativ das ist genau
diese der selbe problem das wir haben
mit unseren extremisten die blenden
genauso generative dass mohammed doch
allen 14 hat in mekka und versuchte
konstruktives zusammenleben und das ist
unser kritik immer ein kritiker die
sagen ja moment hatte ich als sie
spazieren limitierung der gewalt und sie
sprechen von einem grausamen problem es
gibt einen anders als dieses jahr nehmen
wir haben ja eine nation ich gebe ihnen
ein anderes beispiel was im buch von hat
das damals auch ein sehr schönes
beispiel auch ford kommt abraham er sagt
abraham war auch ein faschist weil er
befehl bekommen hat sein sohn zu
schlachten und erst gehörten einfach
sagt jetzt schwer so vater aber nur zur
erläuterung der eben auch in alten
testament seinen sohn als opfer dar
genauso eine jüdisch christliche
geschichte gerade jetzt ist dann am im
letzten moment wie nicht im monat gehört
ihr opfer da gehen da und wie geht man
mit der geschichte umgeht
ein narrativ eine lese hier geht es um
mindesten gehorsam um unterwerfung von
einem diktatorischen gott der sagt
machst und mach es einfach es gibt aber
an das narrativ andere erzählung ja es
gerade dieser gott wollte ihm sagen eben
es geht nicht darum den sohn zu
schlachten deshalb habe ich jetzt ein
video oder was immer an seiner stelle um
ein abbruch hier zu demonstrieren mit
einer alten tradition bei der
eigentliche theorien also erledigt
das ist das was wir unsere studierenden
bringen der christliche leseart und die
kenne ich auch dass das war ein bruch
mit der tradition des menschen opfers
aber eins geben sie mir einen einzigen
interpreten des korans der dieser
geschichte so interpretiert nein sie
neigen dazu dieser geschichte alles
gottes befehle auszuführen ohne den
moralischen gehalt diese geschichte
infrage zu stellen
rein menschlich rein menschlich wir
haben ein vater und haben einen sohn und
der bekommt ein befehl von gott im koran
nicht nur in einem traum wie in der
christlichen sondern ein befehl töte
dein sohn dahin so das war tötete dann
dein sohn dann gibt er und will ihn
umbringen und dann kommt dieses opfer
und dann wird er gelobt aber haben im
koran dass er das den befehl gottes
ausführen wollte nicht dass es das und
das und das verankert genau diese uhr
faschistische idee
man sollte die befehle ausführen wenn
sie von dem führer kommen ohne den
moralischen gehalt ohne die
menschlichkeit zu betrachten weil der
führer dazu will und aber haben wir
dafür gelobt nicht dass er seinen sohn
nicht opfer sondern das opfern wollte um
gottes der verheißung das ist die eine
lesart das ist eine interpretation wir
haben inzwischen über 800 studierende
schon mit den stunden dieses jahres in
münster
wir lesen das anders wir interpretieren
das völlig anders als abbruch mit einer
tradition wo man das kind übrigens
dieses
und wo die leute fortgeführt sie kennen
das in der biografie mohammed als sein
vater so lange geschichte da wollte man
das mit seinem vater schon machen da ist
etwa das zehnte männliche kind der vater
von mohammed abdullah und wollte man ihn
opfer ist war gang und gäbe dass man ein
kind geopfert hat für gott und da kommt
dieses narrativ diese geschichte um
abbruch damit zu machen
es ist in der tat dann die frage wie
lesen wird das ist es nicht die frage
was steht das was steht ist ist ist
stark wie bringen wir die namen kennen
indem wir menschen das lesen die frage
ist gelesen wird das warum lesen sie das
so warum liest ein zelt zur sicheren
stelle viel zu schauen jetzt würden sich
über mich aufregend sind eher auf ihrer
seite und sagt er nein nein das war so
einsam jüngsten investieren wörtlich
nicht nur wörtlich sondern im sinne
eines diktatorischen gottes und das ist
das problem bei salafisten oder
überhaupt eine vorstellung von einem
gott der für sich das braucht also
gehorsam sonst nicht beleidigt als gott
aber ich sage immer den menschen aber
wir sprechen dann nicht mehr von gott
wir sprechen von einem minderwertigen
wesen nicht mehr von gott wird uns
kommen hier passieren so das war das
ende des menschen opfers also wieder
gewalt legitim aber dann also eine
ethische ansage man soll das beenden das
ist das wirklich an einen der gesund
wäre es anders interpretiert viel
anderes ist es ist in ordnung das ist
andere und unterschiedliche
interpretationen gibt aber was ist das
für ein gott der im koran direkt der
tötungs passagen oder befehle gibt und
sich darauf verlässt dass die menschen
das nicht so ernst nehmen wie er das
gott spricht im koran und das ist ja das
hauptproblem mit zement wissen nicht nur
das was im koran steht sondern die
geisteshaltung der muslime gegenüber
einem grad
alles das unverfälschte direkter wort
gottes an die menschen gott hat die
muslime auserwählt um zu ihnen sein
letztes wort sein manifest sozusagen zu
das ist das problem
und wenn muslime das lesen unterstützt
tötet die ungläubigen oder enthauptet
sie verstümmelt sie
schneidet ihren die beine ab ja ich
steigt auf ihre finger hälse
das ist was ist das für ein gott der im
koran ins oder vier sagt und schlagt sie
also ihre frauen also wenn die frauen
wieder spritzig werben dann schlagt sie
und dann für sich darauf verlässt dass
es ein kluger theologe 20 14 100 jahre
später kommt und sagt damit ist nicht
unbedingt gemeint schlag sie ist und
dann vielleicht nur pupsi weg oder so
das ist alles eigentlich absurd und man
kann wenn wenn man wenn man eine
religion der barmherzigkeit ist dann
sollte man direkte klare ansagen also
wenn jesus sagt liebet eure feinde
dann kann ich das ich hab zu viel
gelernt dass gar nicht gefällt seine
verse aus dem koran für mich heraus
ziehen soll und so sozusagen aus dem
sondern zitieren soll
gleichwohl jetzt diese stellen gibt es
ja schlagt eure fragen zum beispiel wie
gehen sie damit um
eben genauso historische kontext
realisieren was war damals los man hat
zugeschlagen als erstes mittel um
konflikte zu lösen in einer
patriarchalen gesehen sehr stark
patriarchalischen gesellschaft jetzt
kommt der koran in der vierten zeile und
sagt es gibt andere meditationsform
entspricht miteinander macht dies macht
jenes und gewalt an letzter stelle
natürlich für unsere heutige zeit wenn
wir mit unseren heutigen augen wo für
menschenrechte haben diesen tieren ist
ein wäre ja wieso steht es aber noch
immer drinnen mit dem schlagen
denken sie jemand dass es ein buch das
im siebten jahrhundert entstand ist wo
gewalt an erster stelle gekommen ist
dass gewalt zurückgereiht wird an
letzter stelle
in diesem vers das ist für damals ein
progressiver schritt ein revolutionärer
aufklärerische schritt wie damals es ist
nie ausgereicht wenn ein gott ein mann
erlaubnis gibt wenn die frau wenn er
befürchtet dass die frau wieder günstig
ist es nicht denn die frau tatsächlich
die spitze sondern da man befürchtet
dass sie widerspenstig ist und schlagt
sie warum hat er gott der barmherzige
pass nötig
und warum mussten wir im
einundzwanzigsten jahrhundert ja alles
intelligente menschen die kant und ruß
so gelesen haben die die aufklären unter
sich haben hier und an diesem tisch
sitzen und in diesem vers herum vor
stellen und zu sagen das war damals
aufklärer ich uns wozu brauchen sie dann
dem koran alles moralisches vorbild
überhaupt moment für verwässern es mache
ebene
sie haben vollkommen recht aus unserer
heutigen perspektive protestieren wir
über diese stellen auch viele stellen
alten wm neunter ist damit genauso dass
ihr protestieren dem wird eben sein
wieso gibt es diese stelle überhaupt was
ist das für ein gott aber das seien sie
heute im 21 jahrhundert sie und ich im
siebten jahrhundert hätten wird das
nicht gesagt weil wird nicht so weit
gewesen wären genau das
sozialversicherungs erklärt oder es gibt
mediation es gibt das gespräch dann
kommt die gewalt das ist war in der zeit
ein fortschritten im moment sie
argumentieren ja genau
fundamentalistisch wie diejenigen die
sie kritisieren am schluss noch nie so
ausleben gehen sie wieder zurück und
sagen nein hier steht die gewalt und
deshalb was ich sage am ende ist die
gewalt passagen sind historisch zu
verstehen und die wunderbaren toleranten
passagen auch wir waren auch nicht von
mohammad für alle zeit gemeint sondern
situation bedingt und deshalb das
disqualifiziert den koran ja alles ein
moralisches buch das wir im 21
alles grundlage für unser moralisches
handeln es gibt jetzt andere bücher die
moderner sind die
menschenrechtserklärung steht für mich
über den koran und das erwarte ich von
einem aufgeklärten theologin da sagt wir
haben die menschenrechts erklären und
wir müssen das rad nicht neu erfinden
wir müssen nicht irgendwie herum
wurstens im koran indem sie schreibe
hier rausgehen ja mit einer ganz anderen
haltung dann an dieses buch heran
jetzt noch mal zurück zum stammvater ein
stammvater der juden der christen der
muslime
sie schreiben in ihrem buch der
faschismus ist in gewisser weise mit dem
monotheismus verwandt ist für sie das
christentum das judentum auch
faschistisch und das christentum und das
judentum haben sicherlich faschistoide
züge die sie durch selbstreflexion und
aufklärung gearbeitet haben und sich
davon gelöst haben es gibt andere
christliche und jüdische
fundamentalisten die immer noch diese
faschistoiden züge habe jeder
absolutismus hat faschistoide züge jede
ideologie die xxx lose exklusives tisch
ist die anderen ausschließt hat
faschistoide züge aber das judentum und
das christentum haben im laufe der
jahrhunderte gelernt hat so nah mit der
eigenen tradition umzugehen
diese gewinner natürlich gibt es in der
bibel natürlich gibt es in der bibel
auch gewalt was aber es sind jetzt keine
tötungs befehle direkt von gott an die
gläubigen ungläubige zu töten sondern
die beschreiben bestimmt der situation
heute die meisten christen wissen dass
das alte testament ist jetzt nicht ein
wort das von gott direkt an einen
propheten offenbar wurde sondern wurde
auch von menschen im laufe der zeit
bearbeitet und geschrieben und die
moderne die aufklärung hat menschen in
der lage in die lage versetzt sich von
ihrer tradition ein stück zu
distanzieren und dieser distanzierung
ist notwendig um die texte zu
relativieren
und hier ist er wie sie arm sind vor der
aufteilung stecken geblieben das problem
ist wenn man erwartet dass der koran
sowie zusammen auch erwartet vom koran
dass er anweisungen also moralische
anweisungen gibt und dem kritisierte sie
der koran ist an erster stelle kein kein
buch der ethik an erster stelle ist ein
buch der spiritualität gott stellen sich
selber vor bemüht sich auch dass der
mensch auch eine spirituelle beziehung
zu ihm kommt ihn kennen während das ist
aufgabe des koran sein erster stelle
wir haben auch unsere vernunft das alte
diskussion in der islamischen tradition
ist der vernunft wird erzeugt die
vernunft das gute und das schlechte oder
die offenbarung und ich glaube wir
erwarten zu viel wenn wir sein für das
einundzwanzigste jahrhundert erwarten
wir vom koran
das wird drinnen jetzt mal alles
detailliert nachlesen können das wollen
die die die extremisten bei uns aber der
islam also der koran gibt allgemeine
ansagen vor allem wenn er eben durch
dadurch dass er betont 55 uhr
aber manch anderer insider der
barmherzige den menschen erschaffen hat
in seiner gott in seiner rolle als die
barmherzige hat er uns erschaffen
also wir sind sozusagen ein produkte
barmherzigkeit gottes ist reicht mir
schon winterkorn auch an mich glaubt sie
seien sie kritisieren sie seien wozu
brauchen wir ein coaching nach 1400
jahren der uns dann erklärt was im koran
ist ich sehe darin eine würdigung gottes
des menschen auch im einundzwanzigsten
jahrhundert dass er eben sagt ich habe
dir mein wort gegeben ist schickt keine
propheten gerade nicht da du hast du
ruder in der hand
interpretiere und wieder profit selber
gesagt hat alles was im sinne der
menschen ist ist im sinne gottes das
heißt gott sitzt nicht da und es
beleidigt wenn man das so oder so
interpretiert sondern erst beleidigt
oder in sorge
besser gesagt nicht belangen so wenn wir
den koran menschenfeindlich
interpretieren und ich glaube das ist
der gemeinsame nenner auch wenn wir in
die zukunft gucken und fragen nach
welchem islam streben wir welchen welche
interpretation des islam wollen wir dann
brauchen wir einen gemeinsamen nenner
und das ist der mensch und deshalb ich
sag dir gott an den ich glaube an gott
den ich im koran lesen ist ein gott der
an den menschen glaubt wunderbaren der
zweiten sure wenn der schöpfung
erzählung als der engel an den menschen
nicht geglaubt haben gott sagt doch ich
glaube aber an den menschen wenn wir uns
einigen
wir glauben an den menschen der wiederum
interpretiert wie immer und ich glaube
sie haben mit mir weniger probleme als
mit muslimbrüder salafiten denn glauben
sie auch daran dass es menschen gibt die
aus dem text auch das gute rausholt und
dann gehen wir gemeinsam die sind ich
hatte eine
hat ja eine großmutter die eine gläubige
muslime war die friedlich war die noch
nie von gewalt oder sowas gesprochen hat
natürlich kann man aus seiner religion
auch frieden begründen mein problem ist
die sagen gott hat uns dieses buch
gegeben und dann hat uns überlassen mit
diesem buch und um damit wir daraus
machen was wir sind oder was wir wollen
dann bin ich die islamische geschichte
betrachtet was im namen dieses punkts zu
sein wir selber bei den muslimbrüdern
genau in ägypten genau und wenn ich sehe
wie viele menschen im namen dieses
buches umgebracht worden sind dann muss
ich sagen dass dieses projekt gottes
eigenes geschafft hat ist dann hat er
die menschen oder missverstanden wo
einer religion ist gerade en vogue die
weltwoche ist der islam böse cicero die
neue züricher zeitung töten im namen
allahs ein großer artikel von martin
rohm heimat was hier nicht steht als
professor an einer universität des open
steht also der rechts konservative
bewegung innerhalb der katholischen
kirche alles wasser auf die mühle der
rechten der konservativen passiert sind
ich lasse diese erpressung nicht zu wir
haben ein ernsthaftes problem mit dem
islam und mit der interpretation des
islam und wir können nicht schweigen und
sagen der islam ist eine religion des
friedens und der religion der
barmherzigkeit und all das was wir sehen
ist sind sind nur phantomen 1
alles was wir säen hat auch mit dem
islam zu tun wir müssen die probleme
benennen ich es gibt in deutschland vier
millionen muslime es gibt in der schweiz
400.000 viele würden ihn sagen sie
beleidigen nicht warum wenn ich die
gedanken eines menschen kritisieren dann
nehme ich diesen menschen die würde
nicht ab wie wenig ich habe mit religion
wenig oder nichts ja ich gehe wie sie
auch nichtmuslime die mit religion wenig
oder nichts zu tun sondern muslime die
im namen ihrer religion töten im namen
ihrer religion frauen für steinigen im
namen ihrer religion ihre mädchen nicht
am schwimmunterricht ich eine absolute
minderheit die mehrheit ist irrelevant
wenn sie untätig ist
die nationalsozialisten waren auch eine
minderheit irgendwann in der
gesellschaft aber alles sie am ruder
waren dann hatten sie das sagen in muße
leben zwei millionen muslime
die normal sind die mehrheit was tun sie
gegen 10.000 isis kämpfer gar nicht die
mehrheit ist irrelevant wenn sie sich
gegen solche auswüchse nicht wert man
kann sich in seinem schlafzimmer
zurückziehen und sagen
islam ist die religion des friedens aber
wenn man zulässt dass dieser von der
mentalisten im namen des islam alters
durchsetzen ohne sich dagegen zu wehren
wir muslime sauer auf mich sind sagen
sie beleidigen mich wenn ich leute sie
nicht beleidigen nun ist sie beleidigen
dann sind dann sind sie auch ein teil
des problems sie haben ja gar nichts mit
dem zu tun oder nach der nach dem
erscheinen ihres buches der
autobiographie mein abschied vom himmel
2010 war das wurden sie dann bedroht mit
einer fahrt war schon in die ecke und
dann nach einem vortrag im jahr 2013
eine todesdrohung sie leben seither
unter polizeischutz
ja ist das nicht auch faschismus
irgendwie wenn man für seine gedanken
ich habe in meinem vortrag was ich in
meinem buch aufgeschrieben habe der
islamische faschismus hab meine thesen
das sind gedanken ich habe nicht gesagt
schafft muslime aus der welt weg sondern
ich habe gesagt in dieser religion in
diesem buch ist unglaubliches
gewaltpotenzial und das hat sich immer
im laufe der geschichte viele hier die
bedroht ich bin ich fühle mich nicht
mehr ich bin bedroht das war nicht nur
eine bedrohung sondern das war ein
mordaufruf dreifach im ägyptischen
fernsehen von menschen die millionen
anhänger haben die hacker auch kennt
unbeobachtet und das sind auch
dimensionen die für mich komisch sind
wenn ein mohammed karikaturist nur eine
bombe im turban des propheten zeichnet
dann sind muslime aufgebracht und sagen
der
unser prophet in zusammenhang mit dem
mit gewalt zusammen gebracht wenn ich
ein buch über den islamischen faschismus
schreibe dann sind sie aufgebracht und
sagen er beleidigt uns und dann werde
ich sogar mit dem tode bedroht
aber wenn diese leute mit eine flagge
durchlaufen wo der name mohammed
geschrieben ist wieder da
glaubensbekenntnis des islam geschrieben
ist
dann zählen sie sich auf einmal dieser
wunderbaren friedlichen muslimen nicht
beleidigt dann gehen sie nicht dagegen
vor sie wurden gegen vogel aber sie
gegen sie gehen nicht gegen menschen die
im namen muhammad töten die schweizer
bischöfe gesagt die muslime sollten sich
auch die verbände doch mal klar dazu
äußern
die verbände haben dann gesagt das haben
wir aber längst gemacht haben sie von
dieser gewalt distanziert in ihrem
alltag sie haben jetzt vor kurzem auf
facebook gesagt ich verlasse deutschland
was heißt denn dass diese bedrohung für
ihren alltag
ich kann nicht mehr normal leben und ich
will auch nicht auf dauer unter
polizeischutz leben und wenn kritische
stimmen immer so an den rand gedrängt
sind da helfen mir auch dieser millionen
muslime nicht die sagen der islam ist
friedel die waren ihre hand in unschuld
und sagen immer das ist wie ein mantra
das hat mit dem islam nichts zu tun
natürlich hat das mit dem islam kommt es
eigentlich dass sie bei den muslimischen
wurzeln eben libanon aufgewachsen dann
in saudi arabien als kind so
unterschiedliche interpretation und
erlebnisse mitbringen weil der mensch
wächst wir sind kinder unserer kontext
akin der unserer zeit das was wir
anfangs gesagt habe ist haben wir es
gibt nicht den islam im sinne des der
für sich spricht sondern wird menschen
aber in saudi eingravieren da ist ein
strenger auslegung des islam
frauen und männer getrennt ich weiß
nicht fahren die nicht befahren dürfen
da sind sie als kind aufgewachsen aber
zugleich ich komme aus einer
palästinensischen familie dem libanon
aufgewachsen ist wir waren immer im
sommer im libanon wo ich ganz was
anderes erlebt haben 50 prozent der
bevölkerung über muslime 50 prozent
christen 50 prozent der muslime sony der
anderen städten
wir sind eine sunnitische familie zwei
meiner onkel sinne schiitischen frauen
verheiratet das war nie ein thema also
wo heute zwischen sunniten und schiiten
das ist ein todesurteil ist da waren
ihre onkel verheiratet genau ist es ist
eine eine also normalität und wenn man
so aufgewachsen ist in einer familie wo
vielfalt dazu gehört aber in der schule
was anders rennt das war für mich
ausschlaggebend anfang zu ein
bewusstsein dafür zu entwickeln
es gibt unterschiedliche deutungen des
islams aber nicht nur das man hat sehr
viel diskriminierungen so da habe er
lebt also auf sozialer ebene
ich durfte studieren keine sozialen für
sicher keine krankenversicherung
krankenhäuser erst der regel ihre
religion
nein wegen weil ich ausländer bin obwohl
ich muslim bin und als ich nach
österreich damals 1980 gegangen bin um
zu studieren würde ich den showdown
studieren durfte am selben tag habe ich
mich eingeschrieben juni gleich war ich
krankenversichert damals für 50
schilling im monat dreieinhalb euro
ungefähr monat und durfte ich zum selben
arzt gehen zudem auch der vermeintlich
ungläubige österreicher gehen darf das
war für mich jetzt klingt banal und
oberflächen aber für mich war das ein
erlebnis
meine eltern angerufen ich glaub nicht
ich bin kranke für sich hat wie die
innen
obwohl sie sehen die ungläubigen da
fängt man an zu überlegen was will ist
nah am eigentlich was für die religion
was für gott von uns warum sollten die
es in der hölle gehen aber wir gehen im
paradies geht es um überschrift und
warum geht das und dann fängt man an
sich viele gedanken zu machen theologie
zu studieren finde ich wunderbar genau
genau genau da da können wir uns langsam
mehr kommen denn erst brauchen sie die
distanz zu dieser dem wenn gläubiger
muslime unter sich sind dann werden
solche inhalte sehr oft photobox
ausgelegt
wenn man die distanz wagt und aus der
distanz heraus das ganze betrachtet dann
kommt die selbstreflektion eigentlich
das was nicht ursprünglich im koran
vorgesehen war den muslimen und islam
müssen eine einheit sein da musst du
musst nach dem islam leben damit er
gottgefällig wird aber die moderne hilft
uns uns davon zu distanzieren dann
können wir die texte relativieren das
was die fundamentalisten mussawi war
dann noch eine geschichte ihr vater ist
ein imam gewesen
das war wahrscheinlich ihre berufung
dann gewesen und punkt wo sagen sie da
der punkt wo sie gesagt da stimmt was
nicht
ich habe den koran den gesamten koran
schon als kind auswendig gelernt und
sollte auch wie mein vater im arm werden
prediger und irgendwann habe ich das
gefühl gehabt ich bin überfordert mit
dieser rolle das ist so groß für mich
ich bin ein normaler mensch mit
schwächen und laster und ich würde gern
auch meine schwächen und meine laster
ausleben und die religion sieht dieser
schwächen alles eine sünde und hat ein
heilmittel dagegen eine erlösung man
muss zeigen und man muss sich an die
gebote halten usw
ist der islam gibt ein unglaubliches
katalog an verhalten was man alles tun
muss wenn man auf die toilette geht was
wie man ist was man isst alters und das
war zu viel und im in mir gab schon am
ende einen in den individualisten der
neugierig warte anders leben wollte der
auch gegen solche inhalte regulieren
wollte und ich habe angefangen
irgendwann als ich erwachsen war
diese inhalte des koran rational zu
betrachten und menschlich zu betrachten
ich habe das gefühl gehabt der ansprüche
an an den menschen im koran sind zu hoch
der humanismus dagegen würdigt die
schwächen wissmann
im gegenteil aristoteles sieht dieses
mängelwesen alles eine chance kant
entdeckt dass und in diesem mängelwesen
in dieser fehlbarkeit des menschen eine
wunderbare chance sehen zu selbst
entfalten aber als voraussetzung dafür
braucht man eben diese distanz und diese
distanz dazu gehört für mich auch fragen
zu wagen die keiner vorher oder weniger
vorhergesagt haben zu sagen vielleicht
ist das nicht einmal das wort gottes das
ganze konnte ja auch ein menschliches
menschlicher produkt sein der aus dieser
zeit entstanden ist warum sehen wir
darin so verhaftet die ganze zeit dieser
göttlichkeit des textes hinterher hängen
was sie denn zu den muslimbrüdern jahres
erst mal musste ich meine familie
verlassen und dann wurde ich mag sie
weil ich mit den lego nichts zu tun habe
und ich war noch jung 17 jahre alt usw
und nach einer weile kommen natürlich
auch kommt der wunsch nach gemeinschaft
nach spiritualität zurück mein onkel ist
gestorben ich konnte damit die situation
nicht zurecht finden und man sucht dann
die spiritualität die moschee das gebet
und dann kam ich wieder zu den
muslimbrüdern und dann habe ich gemerkt
war warum muss man immer eigentlich eine
ideologie verlassen um schutz bei einer
anderen ideologie zu suchen der mensch
kann auch für sich denken da braucht
nicht die religion alles wegweiser und
braucht nicht den marxismus alles
wegweiser man kann selber durch seine
erfahrung durch seine fehler auch etwas
lernen und ich habe gemerkt dass nichts
wertvolle ist alles die freiheit und zur
freiheit gehört dass es keine grenzen im
denken gibt und die religion gibt uns
auch klare grenzen vor gott und
gottesbild kann man nicht in frage
den propheten kann man nicht beleidigen
oder in frei bestimmen den koran und die
wirklichkeit des koran und die
unantastbarkeit den disco kann man nicht
angreifen und eine gesellschaft wie ein
mensch auch kann nicht weiterkommen wenn
die wenn es dieser rote linien permanent
gibt zu mein problem ist weiterhin wenn
ich mir das anhören
also wenn ich jetzt die augen schließe
habe ich das gefüllte sitzt er in
salafist xy oder weil ich keine namen
nennen
neben mir und spricht und sagt islam
gibt es rote linien man darf nicht
denken also das ist genau dieses toten
apostaten getötet im islam darf man gott
leugnen im islam
natürlich ist man es geht jeder der
seinen also es hat keinen sinn jemanden
zu zwingen ist mein sie wissen ja die
absicht in der theologie welche rolle
sie spielt also wenn man ein gebet
bietet nur zu hoffen dass es nicht zählt
gestellt davon wenn man ganze religion
annimmt weil man angst hat getötet zu
werden aber im innerlich wenn man alles
ab deshalb macht kennen sie diese
konzepte die sie zu recht zu recht
kritisieren sie seien immer der islam
ist ja immer wieder islam ist das was
muslime als islam präsentieren und da
gibt es unterschiedliche muslime die
unterschiedliche bedeutete bedeutung ist
freiheit im islam die sie leben wo ist
denn die biografisch bei ihnen zu hause
die freiheit im sinne von wie ich den
islam aus leber ich lebe meine religion
gerade jetzt im gespräch mit ihnen also
dass ich mich als mensch gewöhnt sind ja
offenbar nicht so starr nicht so
einengen nicht einen gott der sie wie
eine marionette führt erlebt dass sie
zum schluss kommen dass lahm ist
barmherzigkeit eben ist ein biologischer
gott und gottesdienst ist wo haben sie
das erlebt in ihrer biografie so mehr
als kind also in
also meine kindheit vor allem im leben
und meine oma also was ich öfters erlebt
haben sich mit ihr auch durchgemacht
haben sie ist anderen verbieten gewesen
übrigens also der hat nicht einmal im
koran ganz bestanden eigentlich aber sie
hat wirklich verstanden worauf es
ankommt wird endlich kann ich immer
wieder erinnern freitags wo sie freitag
für freitag mich auch mitgenommen hat
vor den moscheen wo die armen menschen
versammelt haben kommend aus der moschee
und sie hat essen mitgebracht meisters
brot und käse zugleich typisch für born
und kirche neben den moscheen und da
kamen die armen menschen aus der kirche
war sie wusste nichts kommen spenden
kommt essen trinken und sie gab ihnen
und er hat mir immer wieder gesagt schau
mal da sind menschen der sind menschen
und unsere aufgabe ist gottes intention
nach lieber hier zu verwirklichen und
denen zu helfen ist teil von unserem
auftrag von unserem auftrag als gläubige
menschen
ich habe also damals schon begriffen was
gottesdienst bedeutet leider erlebe ich
das selber auch in meiner arbeit immer
wieder von muslimen gemeinen dass es
leicht ist wenn das geschieht macht und
selber sich für die frommen muslime
hinstellen verbreiten sehr viel über
mich gerade auch lügen
er macht christentum aus dem islam macht
islam hält nehmen stellen aus dem buch
übrigens nicht nur salafisten auch
manche kollegen auch
die religionslehrer ausbilden machen das
und dann sage ich die haben ihre eu
längst nicht besiegt die sind verfallen
unternehmen praktizieren einen islam
nennt
wir praktizieren den islam erst wenn
jeder überlegt welche spuren der liebe
der warmen herzlichkeit ich in meinem
leben ein graben möchte so dass ich
lieber veranlasse in meinem leben
natürlich religiöse rituale sind auch
bestandteil davon aber sind kein
selbstzweck wird und nicht gott
eingefallen er will nichts für sich wenn
wir davon ausgehen wird
religiosität religiöses leben auch
lebendig in unseren alltag und das ist
eine wsa dies wird er das sagen so nimmt
diese hört leser oft habe ich so gut wie
kein problem aber es gibt diese und jene
leser hat aber dann erfahrt sich von
ihrem auch dass er sagt es gibt
bestimmte lesarten bestimmte verstehen
es gibt nicht die muslime und der islam
sondern islam ist immer das was durch
diese interaktion rauskommt und danach
reichen und dann hinterfragen wie gesagt
warum diese muslime zu dieser lese arzt
und der muslim zu dieser laser ist dann
finden wir politische absichten bei den
menschen soziale hintergründe usw
und dann arbeiten wir auch daran damit
diese menschen wollen gesundes herz sage
ich immer ein gesundes herz produziert
in seiner interaktion mit dem islam eine
ein gesundes verständnis von religion
wenn ein rätsel mensch wissen will wie
fromm oder religiöser erste soll nur
fragen wie viel liebe erzeugnisse
letztendlich in meinem alltag nicht wie
viel mal ich gebetet haben stunden der
moschee gesessen bin dann haben wir
einen gemeinsamen nenner haben das jetzt
gut zusammengefasst wir sind auch am
ende unseres gesprächs ich könnte das
sicher akzeptieren die verschiedenen
interpretationen des islam aber auch sie
als herausforderer mit ihrer these ganz
herzlichen dank für das gespräch herr
geschieht ihnen danke ich für ihre
aufmerksamkeit wir sehen uns hier in
zwei wochen wieder
[Musik]